when you guys did your verses you and
boy wondered during the pandemic it was
one of the early ones that was the first
one after swizz and uh timbaland that's
right they didn't even set theirs up
they just got in the car bored during
the pandemic and started playing records
right they were saying ours was you know
set up it was people tuned in and tapped
into that it's crazy too because it
happened kind of like
pre the grammy pre
i think king's disease wasn't out yet
right now there was so much i was the
super underdog big time underdog big
time but i feel like during that versus
you just had to kind of remind people
like yo that's why i was good and that's
what i loved about versus in the early
days is it was giving you know you know
flowers to the people that don't
normally get you know the flowers or
whatever so i feel like that that was
the aspect that was so ill to me and it
felt really organic there was something
about it not being as
produced when it was just like yo we're
going live we're in i'm in my spot
you're in your spot that [ __ ] made it
intense yeah i think it made it intense
and i just think it it introduced like a
unpredictability that like once they got
it like really together it was like yeah
it's like kind of watching a tv show now
yeah yeah for sure that's where for sure
yeah it's super produced in high level
high quality there was something about
like you know uh yeah my connection was
yeah people trying to figure out the
sound like when rizza and primo were
trying to figure out like
yo yo yo no no try this try this it was
just something about that that
was like vintage versus like i didn't
even know the last uh
eight ball on mjg [ __ ] i didn't even
know that [ __ ] was going on when it was
going on i seen people like yo i didn't
even know it was a versus happening
right now yeah i think the last verses
that i was really honed in on was the
bone thugs one with three six okay just
because i'm a big bone fan and i just
wanted to see how that went that's
what's up and it was an entertaining one
because busy bone got extremely uh
emotional and uh
last big one i remember it was the gucci
and jeezy one that was probably the no
was that uh was that before jadakiss you
know what was that after that was before
i was before so maybe he had a jada kiss
joining that was like the pinnacle yeah
i think the kiss moment is like the
greatest versus
performance ever yeah for sure i think
jada um
it was the rawest hip-hop moment it's
the most raw [ __ ] cuz he won the verses
by just being like
like that freestyle he did was like it
was like dude like that's just rapping
no no no extras it was the epitome of
why we love hip-hop music like how we
grew up listening to this [ __ ]
it's like kiss just went up there and
put on a clinic like how to perform how
to just
like [ __ ] the hits he had the hits but
like just
yeah try to do this you guys are rapping
over your tracks over there
shout out to kiss man yeah for sure